sur la relation avec la russie c'est
vrai que la confrontation en fait n'est
pas dans l'intérêt d'aucun des deux ça
c'est certain
elle n'est pas du tout dans l'intérêt
des russes non plus puisque vladimir
poutine a aussi échoué dans son pivot
vers l'asie est en revanche les
compromis sont compliquées parce
qu'aujourd'hui depuis 2014 et la crimée
c'est vrai que la nature du régime russe
est très lié quand même à au discours et
à la posture anti occidental est du côté
des états unis c'est vrai que c'est très
compliqué de passer un vrai compromis
avec la russie
à terme la mécanique américaine c'est là
où on est quand même là aussi
différentes 45 c'est que l'idée de
manoeuvre américaine c'est de faire la
réciproque de ce café qui signèrent en
72 c'est à dire qu'en 72 l'ennemi
principal c'était l'union soviétique la
chine étaient alliés il avait réussi à
isoler la chine est ensuite d'union
soviétique a fini par tomber aujourd'hui
la manoeuvre est inverse c'est à dire
que l'ennemi principal ses tâches et la
chine il faut essayer d'éviter l'union
de ces pays autoritaires et l'idée de
manoeuvre ce serait un jour d'arrivée à
détacher
la russie de la chine mais aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup trop tôt parce que
internationalement ça n'est pas possible
parce qu'aussi je le répète
bayonne a conscience que les états unis
sont quand même aujourd'hui trop divisés
pour faire de la très grande politique
étrangère donc le but de buydens c'est
déjà de stabiliser le système de
concentrer les forces sur la chine est
de pouvoir réunifiée l'amérique
[Musique]